[Music]
an apple a day keeps the doctor
away home is where the heart
[Music]
is a constant guest is never
welcome a fool and his money are soon
[Music]
parted the greater the danger the
greater the
[Music]
honor take no notice of the stupid
things people
[Music]
say when one is hungry everything tastes
good hunger is good
seasoning look after the pennies and the
pounds will look after
themselves whom the the God's love dies
young never spend your money before you
have
it as soon as one goes out the window
another one comes in the
door every dog has its
[Music]
day a good payer will not object to
leaving a
deposit
to in distress Mak sorrow
[Music]
less at the game's end we shall see who
gains it never rains it
pours we must live by the living not by
the
dead half a loaf is better than no bread
[Music]
of all pains the greatest pain is to
love but love in
vain old friends old wine and old gold
are the
best let bygones be
bygones to each his own God is watching
over
everyone
each person knows where problems
lie a few germs never hurt
anyone when good cheer is lacking our
friends will be
[Music]
packing appetite comes with
eating patients time and money
accommodate all all
[Music]
things little strokes fell Great
Oaks A change is as good as a
rest to Heir is human to forgive
Divine never give advice
unas a soft answer turneth away
wrath when drums beat laws are
silent do what is right come what
may I don't care what people say as long
as I get what I
want a Miss is as good as a
mile
we're all a little crazy in one way or
[Music]
another make the best of a bad
bargain all of us have been fools once
in our
lives you can judge a man by the company
he
[Music]
keeps birth is important but breeding is
more
important God sends cold after
clothes there's no smoke without
fire poverty breeds
discontent Love Will Find A
Way married people need need a home of
their
[Music]
own money goes where money
is nothing succeeds like
success it's no crime to steal from a
thief Mischief comes by the pound and
goes by the
[Music]
ounce
the greatest hate Springs from the
greatest
love imitation is the sincerest form of
[Music]
flattery actions speak louder than
words dead men have no
[Music]
friends a faint heart never won a fair
lady
he that would have the fruit must climb
the
[Music]
tree if at first you don't succeed try
again the early bird catches the
[Music]
worm if you don't have what it takes you
won't get on in the
world no Bees no honey no work no money
no meal no
meal sometimes the remedy is worse than
a
disease one can never know too
much we are all equal in the eyes of
God Time Heals all
wounds
there's small choice in rotten
[Music]
apples many hands make light
work the Shoemaker Sun always goes
Barefoot any port in a
[Music]
storm more than enough is too much
A friend in need is a friend
indeed things have changed time doesn't
stand
still he who excuses himself accuses
himself the grass always looks greener
on the other side of the
fence
what can't be cured must be
endured there are plenty more fish in
the
sea the walls have
ears the devil looks after
[Music]
himself a rolling stone gathers no
Moss
one good for wit is worth two after
[Music]
wits abundance of things engenders
disdainful absence makes the heart grow
fer anger is a brief
[Music]
Madness A Woman's Place is in the home
necessity is the mother of
[Music]
invention if you talk too much you're
likely to give yourself
away discretion is the better part of
[Music]
Courage
laughter is the best
[Music]
medicine health is better than
wealth if a man sleeps with two women
they will soon find out that neither of
them belongs to
him if you go away you can't expect
people to keep your place for
[Music]
you strike while the iron is
hot things happen when we least expect
[Music]
them he who is Born to Be hanged shall
never be
[Music]
drowned
for